today we have eight challenges and we're
giving out 800 whenever someone wins we
move on to the next game you win 100
bucks if you hit him you have three
shots
I get a three hundred dollars
have you have you played table tennis
five years okay you're gonna lose this
one okay
is that he was going to keep moving okay
no you can't you can't come on come on
that was terrifying dude it's just
coming up
awesome
challenges to beat me in bouncing with
the spoon set the score
seven is the score to beat
one two three four oh that is hard
five I mean this is not a flat surface
man one two three four
I'm not gonna lie I do stuff like this
all the time
I will get zero one two three four was
it just three
one two three four
you can accomplish anything you want in
this world thank you so much make sure
to subscribe to pongfinity are you up
for the pillow fight I'm ready to cats
it's five pillar bounce the ping pong
ball okay and you get to use the pillow
and try to hit the ball away from me
pillow attack
oh when is the hit Gonna Come
oh
It Blow it's very solid defense thank
you first attack oh those are still
bouncing
thank you guys
came from behind when is he gonna attack
I didn't see it that's coming who
dropped this first I might have dropped
it first
still unbeatable
[Music]
I'm only getting better at this oh one
o'clock oh he's picking up the pillow
[Music]
oh my God that's it too yeah while
holding the pillow that's harder than
that
oh my God if I can't do it then nobody
can do it so let's prove that it's
possible
that was a vicious strike
okay we're out of money now so sorry no
more no more I feel like I'm a bit
sunburned let's get Otto back in the
shade whoever catches the ball with a
spoon wins 100 one try
not easy I hope someone gets it
oh
[Music]
oh you had it for a while
close it so far
[Music]
good try do you consider yourself a good
Spooner sometimes oh 100 bucks this
might be the one
that was so good that was so close you
can use both hands
oh
they had it like a few very close ones
don't believe
[Music]
it's proven to be very difficult I'll
give it a shot somebody's gonna watch
this guy though
100 bucks what are you guys gonna do
with the fries they're gonna get ice
cream 100 bucks worth of ice cream let's
move their next one good transition
effect so the next challenge is to cross
the bar with bouncing the ball good
that's right 100 bucks if you can make
it what about you like to go there and
fast
let's go looking good you've been
playing payable things before I mean
we're friends and then the hardest part
the step down the bar
oh there we have it there we go let's go
easy money Easy Money easy money first
person to cross the finish line wins
oh he dropped it and you and I raced
yeah we race
oh my God she's fast
foreign
[Music]
are you balancing it on the thumb
thank you
oh he's fast he's fast yeah you dropped
it before so you want it a hundred
dollars
nice to meet you Mika against Mika
that's why he won because his name is
also make up the mics all right but how
wet do you think we're going to be after
this challenge it really depends how
fast we're gonna lose if you can get us
to miss the tables in this rally you get
a hundred dollars ready to uh disturb
the rally go oh okay she's chosen the
target keep Focus dropped off yeah and
that's time
it's actually pretty wet there I don't
like water it's refreshing oh I'm a bit
intimidated go
I think he hit the ball
go
oh
[Music]
you got my racket that was too easy 100
bucks yay that was quite refreshing I
quite enjoyed that challenge because
it's so hot outside okay so for the next
challenge we're gonna climb up a
mountain well we're bringing this table
up the hill and whoever wins the point
against us it's 100 bucks
uh one point okay
oh
oh oh
that was a good rally
oh okay ready
there we go the champion of the mountain
you have the hundred bucks
[Music]
yeah he didn't even know he wins 100
bucks
thanks for watching guys remember to hit
subscribe
so it's time to carry the table down